in the gathering of our digital
information where does Facebook stop
where does the NSA begin the lines blur
is young
Zuckerberg lambaste the President
President Obama assesses the politics of
the moment the NSA stands largely silent
we're thrilled to bring you David for
Patrick author of the Facebook effect
and Richard Falcon wrath former White
House security adviser to discuss and
have a conversation and a support matter
David let's get right to it
why is Zuckerberg lecturing the
President of the United States because
Facebook is a consummately global
company for which Trust is absolutely
paramount and since the revelations that
the NSA has treated all American
Internet companies as their private
playground all the American internet
companies have been terrified at the
impact that's going to have on their
global business and they feel that the
US government does not understand the
role they play the economy the globality
of their need for trust you know
especially outside the US is really this
is very important for guys like you and
narrow ties in Silicon Valley Silicon
Alley self I suppose I've been silic
about the where's I come on how do you
respond to Facebook and the others will
help us find the next marginal terrorist
I think they could if they were know if
they knew they were doing it they
probably would be happy to help you know
after all they respond to two subpoenas
they're not refusing to help the
government they don't like to have
things taken from them unwittingly they
don't like people tapping into their
fiber law but they're willing to sell it
right I mean they all sell this they
actually face book doesn't sell it they
sell access to it it's a big difference
and it makes my head explode I mean the
impertinence of doing this to the
President itíd States just in general
for a 29 year old first place exactly
second point though is the hypocrisy
this is a guy who's billions rests on
the ability to data mined data given to
his company pursuant to a Terms of
Service Agreement the president does
what he does pursuant to an electoral
mandate in the Constitution the United
States and this isn't a big well okay
Zuckerberg would argue that he hasn't
been abiding
by the Constitution of the United States
and and every member that Fisher who's
weighed in on this in the last six years
disagrees with him well we don't see the
court ruling so how do we even know
actually you do see the court rulings
the court rulings now are published and
the Department of Justice has released
them do you think any CEO has the right
to call the president and it would be
appropriate first of all that the point
is have anything to do definitely does
it something that it shows why he talked
about it publicly it's one thing to have
a private conversation with the
president which is a privilege all right
the second thing is to tell everyone in
the world what you said which is absurd
I know you don't think any CEO should do
that oh yeah then they mostly don't I
mean I actually cannot think of another
case I mean do the Wall Street CEOs when
they come in to meet with the President
and sector go out this is the
responsibility of the NSA the Pentagon
and others to protect us and yet at the
same time we've got this ginormous
business that you're part of
uninfluenced the most vibrant part of
the American economy that's true there's
a middle ground look the fact is all
these companies are very eager and happy
to cooperate under legal and knowing
terms with the US government but when
they do things as has been revealed like
tap into the fiber lines to their data
centers secretly and just suck all the
data out that's ok fundamentals of
violation of the trust for their users
and they cannot abide so what you're
getting at then is there's this and I
don't say it's legally there's a
distinction between going to a business
entity and saying I'll pay you and you
can use my data as opposed to the
government where you haven't made that
agreement your violates an agreement
right yeah I think well the users of
Facebook for better or for worse
basically trade their personal data in a
free site Richard I want to get you in
here's the last word where is the middle
ground on this good debate the middle
ground is the rule of law and so the
case you talked about is not actually
accurate when the government goes to
Facebook for data it does it under the
rule of law it does it pursuant to a
court order and Facebook's like
cooperation without color is not
voluntary it's quite there's never
refute I want to get both they don't
worry